mark aklan is Britain's most notorious
conmen I was left destitute I did wish
that he had actually killed me in a
thirty-year criminal career he's
defrauded not only his own family I
actually had to go to the police because
he in effect closed down my husband's
business but also countless complete
strangers because we lost money I've
ended up losing my family and ended up
losing my house my name is Martin brunt
and for four years I've been tracking a
Clem around the UK he told me that he
was in the wrong name and he also told
me that he'd served undercover in
Northern Ireland I've uncovered his
extensive criminal network across Europe
I think of Mark Hackel in this cycle but
and now I want to know how were so many
people taken in by a club for so long
anybody is open to be conned if it's the
right Khan for you at the right time in
your life I wonder what would it take to
stop him he knows how good he is at
conning people and tricking them he is a
ripe Roman
[Music]
he literally just walked into my life
late to an afternoon when I was at work
I was working in a very nice boutique in
temporary the Bell pinged on the door I
looked up and there he was and I think
the thing to say about him when you
first meet him is he is someone with
great presence and charisma and so those
are my initial thoughts as I looked up
and saw him standing in the shop I was
completely swept off my feet I felt as
though I had fallen in love that this
was the real thing and of course you
know it when it's the real thing and how
could I ever have even considered any
other previous relationships as being
the real thing Carolyn woods had no idea
she had fallen into the hands of
Britain's most notorious con man mark
Ackland a man of many aliases who had
duped victims across Europe and fleeced
them of several million pounds I've been
covering crime stories for more than 30
years and I've investigated some of the
world's most notorious villains but mark
Ackland story has gripped me like no
other his extraordinary cunning his
ability to convict um's is matched by
his lack of remorse for the suffering he
inflicts and it's become personal over
the years we've exchanged many letters
he told one detective I was obsessed
with him perhaps I am but for very good
reasons since the age of three mark a
claim has been pretending to be somebody
he's not he was born into a respectable
middle-class family in 1973 the eldest
of four children but there were problems
right from the start he had a very
difficult birth it was a forceps and a
suction birth and when he was born you
know he was bruised battered and
whatever but I'd never at the time
thought about it but afterwards when I
had so much difficulty with his behavior
right from the word go
I did begin to wonder whether there was
something in it in the late 1980s a claw
was sent away to board at public school
a t-spawn college he was an average
student but he came top of one class in
Business Studies he could always pick
the winners one of his teachers were so
impressed that he encouraged the
schoolboy Akram to speculate on the real
stock market and gave him 15,000 pounds
money that he never saw again there will
be a series of events no doubt that
would have led to market them at some
points around the age of 15 and 16
retreating into a fantasy world that was
better than the life that he felt he was
living at that time well this might be a
clue to that when he was a teenager at
school one of his teachers gave him
15,000 pounds to play the real stock
market I mean 15,000 pounds for a boy at
that age is an awful lot of money and
what does it tell you it tells you that
actually you've got a great brain that
you can exploit and use but his teacher
wasn't the only victim of the teenage
conman his own father
insurance consultant Brian Ackland was
also a target
[Music]
his son stole his gold MX card and spent
thousands of pounds in London that
Stringfellow's nightclub The Savoy Hotel
and Harrods department store
a club also used the stolen card to hire
private jets and fly his school pals
around Europe to Switzerland Paris and
Tenerife the school boy even managed to
buy this mansion in South London by
conning a building society into giving
him a mortgage of half a million pounds
I actually had to go to the police in
the first instance to let them know that
what he'd done because he'd in effect
closed um my husband's business etc so
we had no alternative he was completely
out of control and let me see anything
we could do it led in 1991 to the first
of many court appearances
in the dock acclimated a hundred and
twenty four charges of theft and
deception the judge branded him a wicked
conman and jailed him for four years he
refused to accept evidence from the
defense that a club needed psychiatric
help there's a common saying among
scientists which is that genetics will
load the gun but its environment that
pulls the trigger so it seems quite
clear that market Klem has dark triad
psychopathic narcissistic and Makaveli
and personality traits but so do a lot
of people a lot of people in business
media politics so what is it that has
pulled the trigger on that particular
predisposition if we look at what he did
he ruined his father and mother's life
forced them to sell their house lose
their business and his other siblings
stop them from getting the education
they might have otherwise got he
basically cleaned his family out what
does that say about him that he was
prepared at that young age to do that to
his family well some people might say
shows he's a sociopath but I'd say it
shows he was a heartless wicked
scoundrel who just didn't care about
anyone else apart from his own
self-gratification Oakland was locked up
in Felton the notorious young offenders
institution I just felt that going to
Felton would either finish in one way or
the other you know he'd either kill
himself and I did get letters saying
that he thought he would kill himself I
didn't know what to do none of us did
really really just very shocked and felt
that it wasn't gonna help his cause at
all which subsequently has been proved
to be right but he was given valium and
he was on valium for a long time and you
know got over it in that way he really I
suppose for him to go in there as a
well-spoken white youth from these born
college would have been an issue
but because he's clever he's very good
at manipulating and influencing people
combined with the fact he went in on a
fold which enabled him to get hold of
private jets I suspect some of the gang
leaders would have held him in probably
some sort of respect and though he'd
being shrewd enough to keep himself out
of trouble but he would have built the
contacts and learned the way to work
within the criminal justice system the
story of the schoolboy con artist was
front-page news
years later the adult a column
complained in a blog that the adverse
publicity had blighted his life using
the name Marc Ross Rodriguez and writing
about his earliest crimes he says this I
was a child not even 17 years old at the
time and paid for my crime the case was
notorious because Britain was suffering
from a financial crisis and most English
people thought it funny that a 16 year
old schoolboy was able to make a mockery
of the city as a result I was severely
punished for my crime I have paid my
time and it is absurd to be paying for
that again again and again
unfortunately it's set in place a domino
effect that has affected the rest of my
life in 1993 Marc a clam won an appeal
his jail sentence was cut in half to two
years and he was released he went back
to his South London roots in Croydon he
was 20 a convicted fraudster he tried to
settle down
he'd been notorious he'd gone to prison
for four years he'd been all over the
newspapers what chances did he have when
he came out what were the options for
him but he could quite possibly in those
days of combat to have continuing his
education because he was well-spoken
from a well-to-do family who were still
networked I suspect and he probably
could have tried to get himself into
some reasonable gainful employment on
the face of it that's what a climate got
married in 1994 and had two children but
on his marriage certificate an
intriguing clue that he was already up
to his old tricks he was working as an
administrator but he listed his
occupation as barrister for five years
following his release from prison
there's no record of mark Akram
committing any crimes but I now know
that he left the country in 1997 and
spent the next 15 years fitting between
Britain and the continent leaving a
trail of duped investors wrecked
businesses and more than one broken
heart
[Music]
in 2012 Oakland resurfaced in England in
the West country since his notorious
teenage crime days it seemed he'd
vanished completely from the public eye
but now he reappeared he told people he
was a businessman and a banker and he
was using a variety of names he was
traveling around the Cotswolds telling
potential investors he was buying
Kimball airfield with a plan to restore
vintage aircraft and during this time he
entered the life of the manageress of a
boutique he was posing as a wealthy
banker based in Switzerland his name
mark only he was immaculately dressed in
a designer suit designer glasses and he
had a continental air about him and he
absolutely exude confidence the air was
electric that is the kind of presence
that he has he knows he's got a presence
he told me that himself that he can walk
into a room and he gets noticed and I
think he very much likes being sent as a
center stage he did try on a number of
jackets and he was in the shop for about
25 minutes chatting to me quite
floatacious very entertaining and just
before he left I gave him my telephone
number which was actually quite unusual
for me the next day the couple had their
first date at a local pub
when I met him I could see there's a
glass of champagne on the table for him
and he got me one and he told me he'd
flown in from Geneva
he was very entertaining that evening
everything he said was you know a little
bit out of my realm but he he was you
know extremely articulate and told a
very good story within days
Oakland was bombarding Carolyn with text
messages soon they started a
relationship I was completely swept off
my feet I felt as though I had fallen in
love that this was the real thing
and he gave you the impression that he
wanted to be with you and it was a
long-lasting relationship relationship
he certainly did I mean it was all a
Sharad but yes he said he'd never felt
like this about anybody what is it about
him that women taped him oh I suppose
they'd like to be spoiled and you know
showered with flowers and gifts and this
what woman wouldn't but some is
obviously more than that on it he
obviously has some sort of charm and
things that I I mean I don't see because
I'm his mother but it's bent over and
over again women have said exactly the
same thing so it's obviously quite a
common trait in us women Ackland took
Carolyn to Kimble airfield
he told her he planned to buy it and
restore vintage planes
she was already dazzled by his Jet Set
lifestyle then he revealed an even more
remarkable story
the most extraordinary thing he did say
to me was that actually all this was a
bit of a cover and that he was an mi6
agent that did sound very far-fetched
but he drove me to the mi6 building
apparently when he'd been called in one
day and I was with him and obviously
disorientated me but convinced me that
he was going in to see his boss and I
saw him walk into
an underground carpark past two armed
guards and I was convinced that he was
going into the mi6 building
I think the mi6 cover story gave him
carte blanche to disappear for days on
end to reappear at any time of the day
or night and he did this in quite
dramatic fashion on a number of
occasions so he appeared one day with
his arm in a sling and he told me that
he was working undercover in Syria and
that he'd been shot and so he appeared
with his arm all bandaged up later
Akram convinced Carolyn he was suffering
from a brain tumor I know you can
imagine I was completely distraught
about that he said that mi6 were worried
that he would start spilling state
secrets and he was under guard in the
hospital but he did manage to come out
and see me in the car and his head was
expertly bandaged with what appeared to
be a little drain coming out of his head
so I was convinced like I saw him in the
hospital at least twice it's a natural
inclination not to question anything
until we see something immediately out
of kilter immediately wrong the man
telling you eat an mi6 agent doesn't
sound normal
well there's a technique that come then
use and it's called roping it's how you
literally pull somebody in and there are
lots of different stages to that so the
very first stage is the first impression
that you make on that individual mark
haplin's got a lot going for him
certainly he's not a bad-looking man
he's a good-looking man he scrubs up
well we think that somebody who's
physically attractive will also be
attractive in other ways as well and
have attractive personality traits
Ackland told Carolyn that he was now
buying and developing luxury properties
around bath one of these was Whitcomb
manner a grade 1 listed Georgian home it
was on the market for 3 million pounds
he said that he was having restoration
work done on the house and one day when
we were together he apparently took a
phone call so I only heard one side of
the conversation I gathered that you
know there was a cash flow problem and
he talked to me afterwards I said what
was all that about and he said oh you
know it's a bit of nothing to worry
about that you know are sorted out and
of course I said well I've got some
money because I had sold my house so I
had all the proceeds of the sale of my
house in the bank and I offered to lend
him I think initially it was twenty-six
thousand pounds and over months that
Seager became much bigger in the end I
lent him everything that I had
Carolyn drew up several loan agreements
for the cash she handed over this one
for the total 750,000 pounds she wanted
to believe that this man was in love
with her was as exciting as he said he
was and that they were going to get
married and live happily ever after so
she would have pushed her doubts to one
side to the extent of giving him all her
money that is extraordinary I think that
you can say that Carolyn Wordsworth was
brainwashed to a degree
she says brainwashed absolutely she was
fed a series of more and more outrageous
lies it's harder to accept the reality
that somebody is playing you they're
lying to you and the life that you think
that you're living it's a sham in the
time we were together a column kept
Carolyn under his control isolating her
from her family and friends then slowly
he began to distance himself he stopped
taking her calls he didn't answer her
emails
eventually it dawned on Carolyn that
she'd been swindled Ackland I'd stolen
her heart and then her money I wanted to
kill myself I was suicidal I did say at
the time to the police of my injuries
had been physical I would have looked as
though I'd been beaten to a pulp
Carolyn didn't know that a club had been
living in splendor nearby through the
many months of their romance he was
renting the old rectory with money he'd
stolen from her what's more he was
living there with his second wife Maria
and the couple's young children
Carolyn woods went to a police station
but she was sent away and told to fill
in a standard online fraud form and she
waited weeks to hear from a detective
when she did hear she felt as if she was
being treated as a suspect after months
of police in action she turned to me for
help
it was the start of a 4-year manhunt one
that would take me from the west country
to the secretive banking world of Zurich
and Geneva to the playgrounds of the
super-rich along the Spanish coasters
and finally to the streets of the
Portuguese capital Lisbon where time
began to run out for Britain's most
wanted con men
you
[Music]
in January 2012 carolyn woods met and
fell in love with conman mark a Clem he
then fleeced her of hundreds of
thousands of pounds I couldn't get
anyone to listen to me I went to the
police station I was sent away told to
report it to Action Fraud online and it
then took about six weeks to get the
case assigned to a police force and I
don't think he believed my story when I
told him and in fact I felt as though I
was treated as a criminal not as a
victim of a horrible crime my
involvement in the hunt for Mark Ackland
began with a text message from an old
acquaintance Martin do you have sometime
in the next few weeks to talk to a woman
who has an astonishing crime story
carolyn woods asked me to help track
down mark Ackland because the police
couldn't she was desperate I discovered
that mark Oakland had been living in the
West Country for more than two years
before he walked into the life of
Carolyn woods I soon found out she
wasn't his only victim Carolyn had given
me one clear lead mark acklin's
involvement with Kemble airfield in the
Cotswolds and it was there that I got my
first breakthrough in 2012 a spectacular
classic car and aircraft show was held
there
vehicles worth millions of pounds were
on display one of the guests invited was
an internet entrepreneur he told me that
a man called Zach Moss showed interest
in his idea to promote rock concerts at
Formula One race meetings Zach Moss
talked about raising finance working
with us how he knew Bernie Ecclestone
and how he'd worked with him in the past
and he sounded what he was saying
basically quite Florida portable mr.
Frampton believed Zach Moss had
organized and paid for the displays but
Zach Moss didn't exist he was none other
than mark Eklund unaware of the
deception mr. Frampton was soon lured
into joining a clubs company it took two
months before I realized that there was
an absolute con and that he was a
complete fraud stuff and what were you
paid nothing but I basically got angry
the first month because there was no no
salary turned up and obviously my wife
was going ballistic over that and then
when the second month came and went
I was already realized that he was a
complete nutter robber and and I started
pursuing him for the money you were
awarded what nearly 20,000 pounds how
much of it did you get didn't see a
penny of him and I don't think I ever
will
I've struggled quite badly with with
with ill health and it's cost me my
marriage I discovered there were more of
a clumsy victims in the West Country he
managed to ingratiate himself with staff
at the prestigious Clifton College in
Bristol it was the run-up to the
school's a hundred and fiftieth
anniversary celebrations once again a
column used the classic car scam to
promote himself with the help of a video
shot at the airfield using the vintage
vehicles as an attraction he persuaded
the school to give him a major role in
fundraising he also arranged the
attendance of celebrities including
television presenter Carol Vorderman
it was through the classic car event
that a club met and began to befriend
the regional head of one of Britain's
biggest charities he told me that he was
in the Royal Navy and he also told me
that he'd served undercover in Northern
Ireland and he started to lift his
trouser leg - show me some scars that
were there from when he was captured and
tortured by the IRA I couldn't see
anything on his leg at all and he then
went into a sort of monologue about his
experience and relationship with Hillary
Clinton which again I you know what even
when I repeat anything how could you how
could anyone ever believe this but the
way this fella put it was it was
intriguing at the time now all of this
just you know I can imagine anyone
listening to this thing well how could
anyone be taken in by all this
once again Ackland was posing as a
swiss-based banker he boasted he could
raise 8 million pounds for the Prince's
Trust donations from his wealthiest
clients it seemed likely a club was
preparing the groundwork for another big
scam he's a prized never ever seen him
or heard from him until you phoned me a
couple of months ago to say do I know
Chuck would mark a column and I said
never heard of him and then you said you
might know him as Zack Moss and then
right you took my breath away
he asked if I could design an airport
and I said curiously enough that was my
degree
projects Bristol Airport redesigning it
neither though I think he knew that yeah
I mean that's that and that's a long
time ago that 76 you know but he'd gone
back and he said I've just bought
Kimball airfield he said what I'd like
to do is take you up there and you can
have a look at it and then I want you to
visit Farnborough Airport and he said
it's absolutely amazing I want to do
that in the West Country you know a clam
also commissioned mr. Hadfield
to draw up plans to extend a luxury
house so he could buy it for five
million pounds he said in fact I'll get
the papers drawn up and we can get it
all signed over and I and I said get it
all signed over when does the money
arrived and he said well when the job's
done I said that need the money to do
the job you know instead of buying the
house at Clem rented it but one night he
and his family vanished leaving unpaid
rent of five thousand pounds so mr.
Hadfield hired a private detective to
investigate this is the private
detectives report it concluded that mark
Ackland or mark Moss as he was calling
himself at the time was a classic con
man who played on his victims natural
greed with the promise of substantial
financial gain at some time in the
future the report said that the police
should be alerted and they were but
nothing came of it
[Music]
I knew that a club had close ties to
Spain he spoke the language fluently and
his second wife Maria was Spanish
after several weeks my discovered that a
column had rented this office in
Alicante on the southeast coast of Spain
the rent for the office was paid by a
woman who'd hired as his PA how much did
you give him four thousand years yeah it
sounds crazy and he said he'd pay you
back yes sure
and did he pay you back no he didn't the
plush office were soon buzzing with
hired staff supposedly drumming up
business in real estate and shipping and
attracting investors one day police
arrived and you know they knocked the
door and they asked for mark and I said
okay but who you are and he just didn't
push me you know like no no we can
inside and they get inside and both of
us a couple they get around mark I said
you have to come with us Oakland was
freed on bail that night he collected
his family and did a midnight flit to
Italy
it took the Spanish authorities for
months to extradite angklung he was
wanted for a property fraud linked to
the UK Akram had been selling luxury
London flats to Spanish Nationals for
vast amounts of money flats that he
didn't own
he was put on trial in Carter henna
after tracking Ackland for so long
finally I'd caught up with him he looked
and sounded Spanish and he held
everyone's attention even in that
setting even in handcuffs he had
charisma in fluent Spanish Ackland tried
to persuade the judges that he was
completely innocent at the time of the
crime he explained he'd just come out of
prison and was trying to build a new
life he said he was asked to help sell
the London flats purely because he spoke
English listening intently were at clubs
victims the Cervantes brothers Francisco
and Domingo album Dion it is it is
roosters apartamentos they all regard
atomization lumber is
a million Taiwan today I want to fund
ASEAN Hispaniola yah yah see that
Evy to just be she was not about
Tennessee and then similar what do you
think of market economy I think of mark
a column this psychopath and today even
a chromosome Spanish lawyer agrees and
says he's a brilliant con man Morocco is
we had Rivera a Theological pas de Cicco
pada been the Lord a woman in can tell
early seventies Oakland was convicted of
the London property fraud and sentenced
to three years he was taken to Mercy as
Central Prison number one I wrote to him
and he invited me to come and visit him
our meeting was followed by a long
correspondence Oakland's letters very in
tone there's anger defiant denial but he
also offers to cooperate with me in
telling his story he says we might even
become friends at one stage he writes I
just want to thank you for the exquisite
way you are treating me later on he
tells me that he's got an appeal coming
up and he can get out of jail if he can
raise bail money of thirty thousand
euros and then he writes this to me it's
in no way that sky can then the bail
money they get it back once the appeal
ends I will never run away again I only
have one last chance I had been
intrigued by Oakland's admission in
court that he had just got out of prison
it suggested that the scale of his
crimes in Spain was far greater than
anyone had suspected to help me explore
Oakland's Spanish criminal career a
former top detective from Scotland Yard
and the City of London police it's
difficult to get a clearer picture of
his crimes in Spain
there's confusion one of the reasons is
I've got a a rap sheet from Spain and a
rap sheet from the crown prosecutors in
England and there are discrepancies they
don't match but what they both do agree
on is a first crime in 1999 what what
have you got there well we've got him in
1999 getting three and a half years for
a fraud he claims it was defrauding a
hotel but you don't get three and a half
years for defrauding a hotel there's
nothing that shows the detail isn't no
but what we have on the English rap
sheet 2004 two more offences what do
they tell us well we've got him again
committing a burglary an offense of
dishonesty that's in Benidorm yeah and
another fraud Benidorm caught in the
same month may conviction another six
months inside now what's interesting is
that the English sheet doesn't have the
next crime that appears on the Spanish
sheet of 2006 he's again convicted of
fraud and he gets a sentence of 21
months in prison yeah I mean what this
is showing us if you now put all these
together is that as soon as he's out of
prison he's back reoffending he simply
doesn't stop he's probably plotting
whilst he's in prison the guy is a
serial offender and a dishonest person
it's still difficult to get any real
detail of what he was up to in Spain in
terms of his crimes but there's one tiny
newspaper cutting that refers to the
crime in Benidorm in 2006 what does that
tell ya this tells us that he had
attempted to convince people he young
the hotel barley just down the road from
here working with a single poor partner
he came unstuck of course because the
hotel owners knew nothing about it but
interestingly this was only within a few
months of him being released from prison
from the burglary and fraud offenses
which he was convicted no for Kevin and
I worked out that over the years Oakland
had been jailed in Spain five times
on his last sentence in 2015 he applied
for a pardon and was freed temporarily
he surrendered his passport and was
ordered to stay in Spain but again he
went on the run
[Music]
for a long time I had been on the trail
of mark Ackland Britain's most notorious
con man I'd finally caught up with him
when he was convicted of fraud in a
Spanish Court in 2015 but on temporary
release from jail awaiting an appeal he
had vanished again in 2016 UK police
finally put a claim on their most-wanted
list
they urged Spanish communities British
expats and holidaymakers to look out for
him the realities for the day-to-day
police officer they are so busy just
getting through what goes on in their
day-to-day work they don't get time to
look at these kind of lists and indices
and so you come to notice because you've
been in a road accident you get arrested
for drink-driving
or you end up in hospital as Spanish
police searched for Oakland I continued
my own investigation for months I've
been working with a foreign private
detective who also had a claim in her
sights she tracks con artists through
online chat rooms she uses the alias
Charlie's Angel because Charlie had
received death threats for her pursuit
of fraudsters she asked not to be
identified
mark Eckland was just one of many later
on he became like a challenge to my
intelligence loads of times I felt that
I was behind one of his aliases was one
step ahead
police had been hunting Akram in Spain
for six months when Charlie rang me
she'd been sent a photograph of a Clem
sitting at a cafe not in Spain but in
Switzerland together we managed to
locate the cafe in the middle of Geneva
[Music]
Akram clearly wasn't a regular there
in what your as falsies
no one knew him Aston Martin
[Music]
I was back to square one as Charlie had
predicted a club always seemed to be one
move ahead
my hopes of finding him in Geneva were
dashed but again I got some unexpected
help
there were people once close to a club
who were beginning to turn against him
just when I think I've hit a brick wall
I get an email from a mystery man who
offers me new clues to acklin's
whereabouts he helps me kickstart my
investigation
he thinks that Ackland isn't still here
in Geneva but somewhere else in
Switzerland
the mysterious caller suggested that I
look for a Clemens Erick and it was here
I discovered that a claim had managed to
get a new passport and create another
identity he had changed his name legally
by deed poll he was traveling under
false identities making use of Depot to
change his name all the time so he can
be the most wanted person in the world
on the name of mark Acton if he's
travelling on a different Passport no
one will pick it up I spent weeks
investigating acklin's activities in
Switzerland and I learned that even on
the run he was still preying on new
victims I spoke to the wife of one of
Acland Swiss contacts she was scared to
talk but said at claire mode her husband
a lot of money the debt was making her
husband unstable she was terrified
because he owned a gun I found that an
extraordinary moving phone call the poor
woman could hardly speak she was crying
so much another country and another
victim mark a compromising huge profits
but delivering nothing but misery and
ruining lives up to his old tricks again
later in a series of text messages and
phone calls the woman revealed that a
clone was running a company making black
box recorders for driverless cars also
he claimed I found a new company in
Switzerland called Swiss disk and the
first thing that caught my eye was the
website of the Swiss disk had exactly
the same layout exert the same letters
used as former marketing websites Akram
claimed he was working with Elon Musk
the American car technology pioneer
Ackland was telling would-be investors
that musk had put five billion Swiss
francs into his new company
he promised us billions one of the
wealthy important companies will become
Swiss disk in the next year and it makes
sense and you invested yes I invested
how much 400 thousand roundabout and are
you going to get that back no never
what happened when you met Marc Oakland
I've never met Marc Ecko in my life
Harold herb ins contact with at Klum was
only ever by phone never face-to-face he
thought he was dealing with a Spaniard
called Manuel escolar I found out and
that all was based on a big fake and on
lies but that the the fake let's say
mano a con sis Cola is finally a man
called Mark Eklund I couldn't believe in
it because I've never heard something
about market loan
how were you taken in he is let's say
brilliant in operating this persons he
tells you a story and after few minutes
you believe in it on the run a clam used
his many identities and the lack of
European border controls to travel
freely
[Music]
one day fraud investigator Charlie's
angel contacted me with good news
Oakland had been spotted in Lisbon
I'd been sent secret photographs of
acklin's disheveled new look but for a
man who changed his appearance so often
it was hard to know how much use they
would be Lisbon though provided the most
important lead yet another mysterious
source confirmed that a claim had been
doing business here and it wasn't just
me who was interested in the Portugal
connection a team of British detectives
flew to Lisbon in great secrecy they
rented an apartment close to the British
Embassy they came to speak to the man
who'd been feeding me information about
acklin's activities detectives from Avon
and Somerset Police and the National
Crime Agency came here to question the
informant they clearly believed he could
lead them to their fugitive they told
him that much work was being done to
find Akram police and other agencies in
various countries were now joined in the
hunt the net was closing but a claw
wasn't to be found in Lisbon
the hunt for Britain's most wanted
fraudster ended back in Switzerland in
the small town of Aiden's Ville Oakland
was at home in a luxury rented apartment
with stunning views over the water swiss
armed police had been watching him for
days before they approached when his
wife let them in Oakland was sitting on
the toilet I think what led to his
arrest was the publicity that Caroline
woods had maintained and Skye had
assisted with to the point where we
received information from Switzerland
that came to Haven and somerset
suggested where he might be
Oakland was taken to Geneva's Chantal
imprison his extradition to the UK was
put on hold a Swiss prosecutors
considered their own charges against him
during that time Oakland was convicted
of more crimes Swiss check and credit
card fraud and jailed for a hundred and
twenty days it sounds as icy for a lot
of companies as well as persons went
lastly to the police or to the
prosecution in order to say hey I'm also
a victim of Mark Eklund back in the UK
at clubs victim Caroline woods welcomed
news of his arrest I've been waiting for
five years for this day
and at some times I thought it would
never come so I'm just now hoping that
he can be extradited it brought to trial
and I can put him firmly out of my mind
forever one of the first things that
Klimt did after his arrest was to write
his wife Maria a letter in it he
declared his love for her and their
daughters he also instructed her to
change certain papers to her name then
he wrote more letters to me at one stage
he complains to me that because of his
past he can't get a fair trial in the UK
and he writes to me rather mysteriously
I believe my life could be in danger
there for several reasons I will explain
in person and in his final letter
he's pleading with me please visit me
here or in the UK you are my friend the
UK can't prevent a friend visiting
helped me Martin I can't cope anymore he
was very keen to get you to understand
that you were friends
he uses the word friend a lot doesn't he
in his letters so you're my friend and
that must mean something to you
therefore you owe me I'm gonna offer you
this great sensationalist story you
won't believe how big it is
but you've got to do things for me
Martin after eight months a column lost
his fight against extradition a team of
detectives brought him back to the UK on
arrival he was charged with 20 counts of
duping Caroline woods into giving him
all her money a date was set for his
trial in the end there was no trial at
Clem did a remarkable deal with
prosecutors he pleaded guilty to five of
the 20 charges the rest were dropped he
was jailed for five years and eight
months time already served in custody
meant his sentence would be much reduced
but if he's made a lot of money I am
sure he has made millions of pounds
throughout his life that extravagant
lifestyle has been based on destroying
the lives of others Caroline woods went
to court to see him jailed and got some
satisfaction from that at least I feel
that I've stood up to him and I think he
probably wasn't banking on that and at
the end of the day although I would like
him incarcerated forever
I have inconvenienced him somewhat so
and hopefully raised his profile after
looking for Marc a column across Europe
for more than four years I was pleased
my long pursuit was over what is it
about Marc Oakland that has so captured
your attention
because he's clever because a woman came
to me who was distraught and wasn't
getting the help that I felt she was
entitled to but is this really the end
of the story of Mark Oakland the conman
he's wanted again in Spain he didn't
complete his last jail sentence there
but eventually he will be free again
he'll be back on the streets somewhere
and it's likely he'll return to the only
life he knows he doesn't seem to have
any remorse for what he's done to other
people and the devastating effect that
he's had on their life but his regret is
that he got caught and the ramifications
of being caught for him frankly he he
knows how good he is at conning people
and tricking them he's gonna carry
straight on back out there the moment
he's released so beware of a con man
called Mark a clone or whatever name he
decides to give himself next